It has been such a joy to pray together with you over these 40
days.
I hope it's been a blessing and encouragement to you.
Let's pray together over day 40.
Father, thank you
for the assurance that you can do more with sin in our lives
than just forgive it.
You can break its power. It is true, you break the
power of canceled sin,
and you set the prisoner free.
And we thank you, Lord, that the foulness of our nature is
not left out of the redemption that we can experience in this
world. We have the fruits of heaven a little early,
and we thank you.
We pray, Lord, that you would look down upon our hearts and our minds,
and that if this friend that I'm praying with today,
if they know the assurance that they're filled with the Holy Spirit,
then let them live continually in that assurance until the
day comes when you take them home.
And if they don't, then Lord, we pray that the
claws of the lion would go deep into our hearts
and that you would let it cost ever so much and hurt
ever so much.
But whatever it takes,
whatever pain, whatever sacrifice,
whatever loss, whatever giving up, whatever surrender,
that you would change us in ways that we can never change
ourselves.
We know that we cannot discipline the nature of sin
out of ourselves. It's going to have to be a work of God.
We didn't put it there. We can't take it away.
But we believe that you are strong enough to do exactly
that. So Lord, help the claws of the lion to go as
deep as necessary to transform us today, tomorrow,
and for always. We pray in the good and powerful and mighty name
of Jesus, our Savior, the one who provided our
holiness,
and the Lion of the tribe of Judah, who is our sanctifier.
We praise you, and we rejoice in what you've done for us in these 40 days.
Now, we ask, Lord, that you would accept our gratitude and help us live in
light of what you've done. In Christ's name. Amen.
I'd encourage you to continue seeking the Lord together for these few minutes
and always. May the Lord bless you.